well let's read about the strange 5g
conspiracy yes The Guardian reports
broadband engineers threatened due to 5g
coronavirus conspiracies eee suspects
telephone masked engulfed by fire and
birmingham was an arson attack as
celebrities claimed kovat 19 caused by
new network i have heard so many
conspiracy theories about 5g and it's
the strangest thing to me because people
say the same things every time a new
radiofrequency technology comes out I
know because I've been dealing with
these technologies for the past decade
yeah I remember WiMAX remember why max
no short-lived 4G technology used by
Sprint they got rid of it they didn't
like it ok switch then everyone started
adopting long term evolution 3gpp
whatever you want to call it I'm not I'm
not an engineer and cell technology
anything like that I just was was
hacking these gizmos and gadgets of my
buddies and we kept hearing that 4G was
gonna cause cancer and all these things
5g that's coming out I hearing the same
things and I just roll my eyes yeah is
why what why would they do that why
would all of these governments conspire
to put out a you know 5g waves that
would kill a bunch of people I don't get
it either what do they think it's like
people die or they they say celebrities
but they're not celebrities they're like
many liberties for saying this stuff
yeah like I was someone someone actually
tweeted me this story and and I was just
like looking into it a little bit and I
was just like this is so silly
like I it's just a bunch of random
people and then I didn't recognize any
of the celebrities granted I'm not
really like I don't really care to like
know who's who in what circles you know
but it just doesn't make sense somebody
actually torched a 5g tower centerfire
series yeah as photos of it going viral
let's read this a guardian says telecoms
engineers are facing verbal and physical
threats during the lockdown a baseless
conspiracy theory as baseless conspiracy
theories linking coronavirus to the
rollout of 5g technology spread by
celebrities such as Amanda Holden prompt
members of the public to abuse those
maintaining vital mobile phone and
broadband networks see already a
celebrity I have no idea who did it was
British like I end up holdin
is the Guardian man it's the UK oh I
don't know that Facebook has removed one
anti 5g group in which users were being
encouraged to supply footage of them
destroying mobile phone equipment jeez
with some Luddites with some
contributors seemingly under the
pretense that it may stop the spread of
coronavirus and some running
leaderboards of where equipment had been
targeted so let me get this straight
is there some kind of conspiracy that
some people are genetically predisposed
to being white yep no wiped out by the
arrive G waves that is that why they're
swabbing people's noses to get a DNA
sample yeah they can be like aha this
proves that the 5g will harm you do they
think that 5g is designed to cold the
masses it's so weird you know it just
feels like they're they're looking for
anything now like oh that must be the
answer
wonderful we can rally against that it's
like I'm willing to entertain they're
made like there's negative side effects
you know I think there was one study
that said that there was you know I'll
tell you what I yeah good I used to
there was a warehouse in Chicago I skate
at they had a bunch of antennas on the
roof and you know the groundskeeper
would say don't go on the roof there's a
lot of radiation it's most it's not it's
it's radio waves and stuff not suppose
to be not it's not an ionizing but uh
he's like trust me man it's a really
really powerful stuff it'll mess you up
don't go up there and that's what the
engineers were saying yeah I saw the
that's kind of in line with what I was
about to say I saw this video I think it
was someone in Russia was it looked like
they were on like maybe the 12th floor
right by the window and they had a
Geiger counter and they would go to the
window and it would spike
and they walked back into the ended like
polarizing radiation though oh is that
what that is but I mean supposed to be
what is that doing to you though is it
to ionizing stuff yeah
breaking down your DNA right exactly so
I mean and he was pointing at the tower
which is like on the roof of the
building next to him I don't believe
that sound that seems I don't know what
I don't know I just remember seeing that
what I well that's a little crazy when I
was right when 5g first like can come
out when I went to Fukushima we had a
bunch of radiation detectors yeah you'd
put it on the ground and it would go
wind like the number without spiking
yeah you could you it wasn't like
pointing at stuff you you'd put it on
the ground and then also in the number
what start going up really
it had to be close I mean it depends
like if there is I guess gamma wave
radiation you'll pick up a ton of it I
really doubt they're blasting that stuff
out of 5g towers does it make sense
that's a that's not how that works and
that was the only time I've ever seen
anything like that and it's only it
seems like it's they've got it in their
start you know companies are starting to
set it up and you know there's no we
have five G is that five G here I've
noticed any problems you have five G
yeah I mean we seem fine yeah we seem
fine nobody don't have again sick
abnormal well let's let's take us out
they say video footage of a 70-foot
telephone mast on fire in Birmingham
this week has also circulated widely
alongside claims it was targeted by anti
5g protesters network operator EE told
the Guardian that its engineers were
still on the site assessing the cause of
the fire but it looks likely at this
time that it was an arson attack the
company said it would be working with
the police to find the culprits it said
quote to deliberately take away mobile
connectivity at a time when people need
it more than ever to stay connected with
each other is a reckless harmful and
dangerous thing to do we will try to
restore full coverage as quickly as
possible but the damage caused by the
fire is significant the problem has
become so bad that engineers working for
BT Openreach which provides home
broadband broadband services have also
taken to posting public pleas on anti 5g
Facebook groups asking to be spared the
on-street abuse as they are not involved
in maintaining mobile networks yeah I
actually in this stuff that was reading
there's images of this different people
straight-up yelling you're murderers
you're killing people to like you know
the guys in the yellow vests like
installing 5g cables you know that
they're just there to pull cable line
you know they're not but people are
yelling I'm calling them murders so it's
like whoa so that's probably what they
were referring to there yeah it's
totally on street abuse industry lobby
group mobile UK's of the incidents were
affecting efforts to maintain networks
that are supporting home working and
providing critical connectivity to the
emergency services vulnerable consumers
and hospitals telecoms engineers are
considered key workers under the
government's guidelines in one widely
circulated video that has attracted
millions of views on Twitter a la
individuals working for the broadband
company community fiber
abused by a woman who claimed without
any evidence that they were installing
5g as part of a plot to kill the
population that's exactly what I was
just referring was yeah right there
that's it this is the way you do it man
if they're there they're there they must
be giant directed energy weapons yeah
that we've been hearing about all this
time really what what is is is this like
you know a Kingsman style plot to to Col
the world because there's too many
people is that what they think it is
maybe I think the movie Kingsman is
actually interesting because the bad guy
makes an interesting point you've seen
Kingsman right I I don't think I have
all right Budhia yeah we've talked about
it a couple times and you've already
Boyle I already know what you're gonna
say right you talked about it that the
bad guy says global warming is a result
of too many people hmm if we do nothing
all people will die so we have to kill a
bunch of people see and you know why I
don't think I remain it cuz I I would
have remembered him having a lisp Sam
Jackson yeah you said he has like this
PA says it I don't remember
Sam Jackson ever has a list you know I
haven't but so the good guys are like
we're gonna stop you from killing all of
these people right but the dude makes
well I guess the point of the movie is
that he's wrong the earth isn't gonna
kill all you know global warming
whatever but the point is the bad guys
like hey look the world's gonna end we
got it we got to you know kill all these
people the good guys are like no you
can't do that is that what these people
think this is basically happening like
the global elites are just are launching
cellular technology that's literally the
plot of Kingsman and they're staying in
4G their 4G networks total so in King's
Aidan away from Karachi in Kingsman the
bad guy gives out SIM cards for free
he's like a tech mogul he's like free
cell phones and everyone gets the phone
and then the phone plays a noise it
makes it which makes them really
aggressive and fight each other and beat
each other to death so it's not identity
riously yes man that's identical what
rate is is that what people believe that
like the 5g is being deployed because
super wealthy people and government and
the secret cabal is like we're gonna
purge the masses like Kingsman is was
Kingsman like a wink-wink nudge-nudge
know maybe it's gotten into their brain
it's it's based in London or Britain
isn't it
so maybe maybe they saw it and they were
like hey that's a nerve hometown
social media posts from celebrities such
as singer Ann Marie have helped spread
the theory foo
well I'm UK men while holdin a judge on
Britain's Got Talent
oh never shared a link to a popular
change.org petition promoting the rumor
that the symptoms of coronavirus are in
reality due to residing near a 5g mast
the petition was subsequently removed
following an increase from The Guardian
international radiation experts have
repeatedly made clear the new high speed
telephone system does not pose a risk to
humans while pointing out that the
corona virus has spread widely in many
many countries without any fight without
any 5g coverage just as Iran yes yeah
Islands
there's someone someone who's saying
that I don't remember I was reading it
but they were saying like you know my
brother my dad thinks that 5 G's causing
all this and their main reason is
because it's it's in all these countries
that have 5g now and it's like well what
about all the countries that don't have
it Iran it's there like they're also
throughout like like Costa Rica there's
Madagascar know what the government the
US government deployed by plane
parachute 5g I've Jeep into Iran to the
kill the satellites yeah world link yes
I think I think the stuff silly you know
it's it's it's I would never just
blindly be like I trust all of these
companies do the right thing yeah I
certainly think we have seen governments
and major corporations dramatically like
screw over people ridiculously you know
that righted and pay a million dollar
fine or a hundred million dollar fine
when they have two billion dollar
profits I got to be really careful about
this next part Oh cuz I don't got the
source pulled out but well they're a
company that produced pills that had
them infected by HIV in the 80s I heard
about this yeah google it just make sure
I'm gonna be careful so look I get it
man but I did
I remember watching a documentary and
that was something it was about
basically like the opioid crisis you
know was it bear is that what who says
that
sortal what's the source legit new
source its CBS news what do they say so
it's a Bayer sold HIV risky meds yep
everyone in chat agrees what clotting
product that stopped potentially fatal
bleeding and hemophiliacs that was
linked to the risk of HIV infection yeah
it was it was it ain't it with it or was
it was contaminated hemophilia blood
products were a serious public health
problem in the 70s and 80s contaminated
with what this is now from Wikipedia
these products cars caused large numbers
of hemophiliacs to become infected with
HIV in Aptos see there you go there it
is there were companies yeah bear is one
of them if somebody comes to me and says
they think it's possible that this thing
would cause you know some kind of
symptoms whatever my immediate reaction
is never like you're crazy
the mood is not made of cheese its I'll
google it I'll look it up yeah yeah and
it's like any sane rational person is
gonna be like that I don't know if I
believe I'm skeptical let me look into
it yeah and I looked into this and I
don't believe it I agree
like the Iran is a really good point
Ron's got a bunch of covert stuff has
nothing to the 5g it was convenient in
my opinion that people have been
complaining about 5g stuff for a while
now there is a real risk with 5g and
that it's disruptive to sell sing a
satellite signals yeah so for weather
forecasting and other stuff like that
it's going to start causing spotty nuts
and that's about it and so far that I've
seen and then all of a sudden COBIT
happens and then someone linked the two
and then you get this viral video with a
woman screaming you're gonna kill people
yeah so no the earth is hollow yes Jason
earth nice and her yeah so I think this
to me sounds a little bit so it was in
Birmingham England right it sounds a
little bit like a case of localized mass
hysteria really because people are like
upset about coronavirus they're worried
they're fixated on one thing there may
be a mist people are saying it they're
like oh this is it is there it is not
just there I've I was looking into this
earlier and it's people in America too
okay no no of course but what you're
saying is that people are trying to find
a reason to explain what's happening
around them and one of the things about
conspiracy theories is that for some
people it's easier to it it's it's
easier to think it's caused by 5g yeah
because 5g is something you have you
have more control over right
okay like if it was 5g doing this you
could say don't turn that on yeah and
you'd save everyone's life it's the
easier zero you could burn a tower and
be a hero yeah that's a saying people
want something to blame exactly because
the reality is they have no control yeah
yep the virus is coming you can't see it
it's gonna get you I was thinking it was
localized but maybe since we have the
Internet it's less localized thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you